eigentlich kennen wir kohlendioxid als
klimaschädliches treibhausgas und die
wissenschaft sucht nach wegen ist
irgendwie aus der atmosphäre zu bekommen
aber jetzt dreht sich alles es könnte
als treibstoff verwendet werden
ein österreichisches forschungsteam hat
jetzt beides geschafft sie haben einen
prozess erforscht wie aus dem
herausgefilterten treibhausgas zudem
noch treibstoff produziert werden kann
und dass zudem auch noch äußerst
effizient wie das genau funktioniert und
ob das jetzt das ende aller klima
probleme dieser welt bedeutet jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit haben der vergangenheit schon
einige ideen vorgestellt um co2 in
andere stoffe umzuwandeln ein
schweizerisches forschungsteam
beispielsweise will bis 2025 ein prozent
der globalen co2 emissionen aus der luft
filtern und damit pflanzen
denn in der richtigen dosierung
eingesetzt sorgt kohlendioxid
tatsächlich dafür dass gemüse schneller
wächst und zwar bis zu 20 prozent eine
andere idee ist es dass co2 in
unterirdischen hohlräumen gespeichert
wird
das ist ja immer wieder ein thema bei
uns noch grandioser wäre es natürlich
wenn das herausgefilterten kohlendioxid
als treibstoff nutzbar gemacht werden
könnte und es gibt bereits methoden die
das ermöglichen doch das problem hierbei
es werden seltene erden oder aber extrem
hohe temperaturen benötigt um die
moleküle aufzuspalten bislang ist das
mehr als unrentabel jetzt hat ein
internationales forschungsteam aus
österreich eine lösung für dieses
problem gefunden sie haben erforscht
dass sich statt der teuren und seltene
metalle auch synthetische polymere
nutzen lassen
diese sind dem melanin also unseren haut
pigmenten nachempfunden diese polymere
sind allerdings nicht leitfähig und
somit als katalysator erst einmal nicht
denkbar also katalysator ist eine
zwischenstation für den chemischen
prozess in einem ersten schritt hat das
forschungsteam diese also zunächst
einmal durch einen chemischen prozess
leitfähig gemacht kohlendioxid kann so
in methan säure und kohlenmonoxid
aufgespalten werden mit andere wiederum
kann dann in einem weiteren prozess im
wasserstoff umgewandelt werden oder
direkt als treibstoff genutzt werden und
zwar für ameisensäure brennstoffzellen
eine brennstoffzelle bei der
ameisensäure als elektrolyt genutzt wird
sie wird beispielsweise energielieferant
für smartphones kameras oder laptops
genutzt werden letztendlich kann man
dieses prinzip mit den natürlichen
prozessen in der natur vergleichen auch
hier neben pflanzen co2 auf und
verwandeln es mit hilfe von sonnenlicht
in biomoleküle wie uns dann
beispielsweise in form von holz als
treibstoff zur verfügung stehen das
forschungsteam aus österreich hat die
stabilität und leistungsfähigkeit in
einem stundenlangen test demonstriert
hierbei wurde kohlendioxid mit hilfe von
elektrischen strom in ameisensäure und
kohlenmonoxid umgewandelt beide stoffe
können wiederum als treibstoff verwendet
werden und würden so tatsächlich den
kohlenstoff zyklus schließen der
effizienz dieses prozesses also die
umwandlung von elektrischer in chemische
energie ist vergleichbar mit der
effizienz die sonst nur bei
katalysatoren auf metall basis erreicht
wird das ganze erinnert ein bisschen an
eine idee eines harvard forschungsteams
das hatte sich bakterien zu nutze
gemacht und diese mit metallen wie
cadmium ausgestattet dadurch bildeten
diese bakterien kristalle auf ihrer
oberfläche aus die an halbleiter
erinnern und den bakterien eigentlich
als schutzmechanismus dienen
doch gleichzeitig versetzen sie die
bakterien damit in die lage
künstliche photosynthese zu betreiben
die cyborg bakterien ziehen nämlich
kohlendioxid aus der umgebung wenn sie
wasser und licht ausgesetzt werden
daraus produzieren sie essigsäure was
dann als basis für treibstoff dienen
kann der prozess ist bislang noch nicht
effizient denn noch total simpel
tatsächlich also sinnvoll dass
forschungsteams weltweit weiter intensiv
an solchen ideen tüfteln dennoch sollten
wir dabei nicht vergessen der prozess
co2 aus der atmosphäre zu nutzen um
kraftstoffe herzustellen trägt nur zu
einem kleinen teil zum klimaschutz bei
diese technologie eignet sich bei aller
euphorie noch nicht dazu
die mengen an co2 aus der atmosphäre zu
ziehen die nötig wären um die globale
erwärmung zu verlangsamen oder gar zu
stoppen
dazu müsste das kohlendioxid dauerhaft
aus dem kreislauf entfernt werden unser
job muss es also weiterhin ganz dringend
sein dafür zu sorgen dass die co2
emissionen drastisch gesenkt werden
hierbei klickst du halt ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video zum thema co2 klimawandel und
so weiter und so fort verpassen wollte
und auch zu allen anderen themen dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
und hier geht es weiter und ich will
wirklich noch mal betonen ist ganz
wichtig was interessiert mich das klima
response in folge 05 da sprechen
klimaforscher mojib latif und ich über
den klimawandel ein richtig richtig
wichtiges video der bundeszentrale für
politische bildung also auf keinen fall
phasen draufklicken und ansonsten bis
dann
bleibt dran